c'est à
nous bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint
dans filcho l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les grandes
lignes de cette émission le ministre
délégué à la ville François lami était à
trappe vendredi dernier objectif
renforcer les mesures pour favoriser
l'emploi dans les quartiers
populaires
15 magasins de bricolage interdit
d'ouverture le dimanche alors pour ou
contre cette ouverture dominicale le
gouvernement va devoir trancher les
bricoleurs du dimanche continuent de
faire pression 300 à 350000 emplois
devrai être créés dans le domaine du
social d'ici à 2030 les besoins restent
importants quel métier englobe ce
secteur pourquoi ne connaît-il pas la
crise c'est notre dossier de la semaine
et puis nous parlerons avec nos invités
de l'action microDON organisé ce weekend
dans des supermarchés du département
Pierre Emmanuel grange bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de l'association
microDON donc à l'initiative de cette
opération les les bénéfices seront
reversés à des associations
internationales et locales pour la
première fois cette année comme baliski
tout à fait i av bon vous en êtes le
vice-président bonsoir on vous retrouve
tout de suite après l'actualité
économique de la semaine très bien
merci François lamille le ministre
délégué à la ville était vendredi à
trappe il y a signé une convention
d'objectif pour le développement de
l'entrepreneuriat social dans les
quartiers populaires au micro de TVfil
il explique les mesures engagées jusqu'à
aujourd'hui notamment pour les jeunes on
l'écoute on aura plus de conseillers de
de pour l'emploi dans les zones urbaines
sensibles que on va développer un
nouveau dispositif qui est celui des des
emplois francs qui va un dispositif qui
qui donne une chance supplémentaire un
jeune tout particulièrement diplômé qui
est souvent stigmatisé à cause de son
adresse voilà et puis il y a la la
Convention qu'on vient de signer avec
bonoamont qui va bien entendu
s'appliquer à trappe mais partout
ailleurs sur le territoire sur le
développement d'entrepreneuriat social
entre autres et puis sur ce qu'on
appelle les clauses d'insertion
c'est-à-dire ces heures de travail qui
seront réservé sur les marchés entre
autres de rénovation urbaine mais pas
que à des jeunes issus jeunes ou moins
jeunes d'ailleurs issus de de ces
quartiers et on s'est engagé dans cette
convention à construire des parcours
qualifiants de façon à ce que les jeunes
qui bénéficient de de ces clauses
d'insertion
une fois que le marché est terminé ne se
retrouve pas de nouveau sur le carreau
quoi contrairement au reste de la France
les Yvelines connaissent un regain de
l'emploi intérimaire plus 4 % en août
par rapport à l'année dernière en
Île-de-France par contre il baisse de
4,1 % le secteur le plus touché
l'industrie le moins le
BTP alors pour ou contre l'ouverture le
dimanche des magasins de bricolage le
débat est lancé retour sur le combat que
mène le collectif les bricoleurs du
dimanche bien présent dans le
département des images d'é lodim
moine 15 magasins de bricolage
francilien ont été condamnés à fermer le
dimanche les enseignes touché le roi
Merlin et Castorama la plainte émane de
leur concurrent Bricorama qui connaît
cette interdiction depuis maintenant 1
an c'est le roi Merlin de boisarcy
échappe à cette condamnation mais les
salariés sont solidaires de leurs
collègues une de leurs actions une
pétition les pétition n'a jamais eu
autant d'engouement des clients ça fait
un an qu'on les fait signer donc elles
ont toujours été là mais dimanche
dernier par exemple ça a été une
affluence phénoménale les gens faisaient
la queue pour venir signer déjà 1940
signatures dans ce magasin depuis samedi
les récentes affaires de fermeture ont
mobilisé les clients Sandy a fait partie
de la délégation reçue hier par le
gouvernement un rapport est en cours
d'élaboration pour régler cette
situation le collectif réclame que
l'ouverture dominicale autorisée pour
les magasins de jardinage et
d'ameublement soit élargi aux enseignes
de bricolage pour Benoît àont venu à
trappe pour soutenir l'emploi des jeunes
le travail dominical n'est pas forcément
sa priorité je comprend la demande qui
existe et qu'en l'occurrence en l'état
de la loi la justice prend ses décisions
en l'occurrence mais moi je suis pas là
aujourd'hui pour parler du travail le
dimanche je suis là pour parler des
emplois qu'on va créer et des gens qui
espèrent déjà travailler lundi mardi
mercredi jeudi vendredi ce qui sera très
très bien et avec un salaire décent
Jean-Paul B missionné par le
gouvernement pour plancher sur ce sujet
rendra son rapport en novembre d'ici là
les BRI ur du dimanche réclame des
dérogations par les
préfets et après le cabinet du premier
ministre Sandy lopin devrait rencontrer
très prochainement le rapporteur
Jean-Paul baahi lundi se tenaient les
premières Assises du crowfunding entend
des finances participativ Olivier Sange
était présent il travaille au parc
naturel de Chevreuse l'une des premières
collectivités à être partenaire pardon
d'une plateforme de financement
participatif en l'occurrence ho merci il
réagit sur l'annonce du gouvernement de
limiter les prêts des particuliers à 250
€ ça me semble effectivement un peu
juste tout simplement parce que lorsque
nous regardons nous notre expérience en
Vallée de Chevreuse on a à ce jour
proposé sur notre plateforme partenaire
et le merc déjà une dizaine de projets
et les les les prêts moyens sur les
quelques 200 prêteurs que nous avons
déjà rassemblés ce sont déjà plus de 300
€ en fait par personne pour des prêts
qui montent dans certains cas jusqu'à
1000 1500 € et il espère ement que les
plateformes soient dispensées d'un
agrément bancaire on annonçait il y a
quelques temps l'arrivée de la 4G de SFR
le 1er octobre c'était au tour de BCK
Télécom de lancer son réseau et cette
fois SaintQuentin en Yveline est intégré
dans le réseau l'entreprise égis
maintenant s'est installée dans les
anciens locaux de malakov méic 30000 M
Carr de bureau entièrement refait à neuf
avec notamment une démarche de
développement durable les équipe était
situé auparavant sur quatre sites on
passe au Technocentre Renault à
guyencour il devrait accueillir de
nouveaux collaborateurs un projet de
rapprochement des sites franciliens
semble se confirmer des collaborateurs
du site de royima maison devraient
commencer à arriver puis autre
information concernant Renault le
service tweezyway est désormais confié à
kimove une entreprise
cquantinoise enfin la vente des terrains
pour la création de l'école d'ingénieur
estaka à Montini a été signée à la fin
du mois d'août le lancement du chantier
est prévu le 15 novembre pour Rael la
Staka est une école spécialisée dans les
transports de demain elle devrait
accueillir 1500 étudiants et on passe
tout de suite à
l'entretien alors l'opération microDON
sera lancée demain dans le département
des cartes de don d'une valeur de 2 €
seront proposé dans des supermarchés
nous recevons sur ce plateau Pierre
Emmanuel grange le président de cette
société solidaire pardon je me suis
trompée tout à l'heure je disais
association mais ce n'est pas le cas
voilà donc vraiment pour faire le le le
lien avec vos reportages précédent on
parle d'entrepreneuriat social donc
microDON est une entreprise sociale agré
entreprise solidaire donc Benoît amont
le ministre qu'on a vu dans le reportage
va faire voter en novembre une nouvelle
loi sur l'économie sociale et solidaire
donc on voilà on fait partie de de de
cette économie un peu un peu différente
on vise à avoir un impact social euh
voilà et le le modèle économique de
notre organisation va venir servir euh
cet impact social et l'impact social
c'est celui de collecter des petits dons
des micro dons avec ce premier
dispositif euh voilà qu'on a mis en
place déjà depuis 5 ans avec le Conseil
Général des evvlin là c'est la 5e année
euh et donc vous allez aller dans une
trentaine de magasins hper hypermarché
supermarché des zvelines à la rencontre
des associations du territoire et vous
allez pouvoir acheter ces petites cartes
euh microDON et faire une micro
contribution de 2 € à la caisse de votre
supermarché pour l'association locale
alors justement pour les pour pour les
associations nous avons en face de vous
Xavier bonarl bonsoir bonsoir donc vous
êtes le vice-président de baliski qui
est une des associations local c'est la
première année qu' que des associations
locales participent à cet événement
alors déjà tout simplement vous êtes une
épicerie solidaire est-ce que vous
pouvez rappel un peu le concept d'accord
alors épicerie solidaire qui a presque
20 ans d'âge puisque ça a été fondé en
1995 sa caractéristique peut-être c'est
d'être le résultat d'un partenariat
entre le département des l et puis
quatre villes Montini voisin guillancour
et
manilame et vous proposez finalement en
fait à des familles défavorisées de
venir faire leur leur courses de la
semaine dans dans votre épicerie alors
ce que je voudrais préciser d'abord
c'est qu'en fait les familles ne
choisissent pas d'aller ou pas à
baliskii mais tous les mois une
commission se réunit une commission qui
est composée bon de représentants de
baliski bien sûr mais surtout des
travailleurs sociaux du département et
des CCAS de chacune des villes
concernées qui sélectionne du coup les
familles qui sélectionne pourquoi parce
que baliski c'est une épicerie sociale
mais un peu différente complémentaire
des Restos du cœur ou bien de la
boutique alimentaire de la ville de
Montini ou bien de boucheaker à à
guillancour baliski s'adresse à des
familles qui sont en difficulté mais qui
sont porteuses d'un projet et qui
passant 3 mois voire un peu plus à
baliski grâce au conseils qui vont êre
donnés par les vol grâce aux conseils
donnés en matière d'achat de produits
alimentaires de produits d'entretien
vont faire des économies faire des
économies par la et grâce à ça sont
susceptibles de s'en sortir je crois que
c'est vraiment ça la caractéristique de
baliski alors pendant 2 jours du coup
des bénévoles de votre association vont
être présent tout à fait voilà Carrefour
Market alors Carrefour Market à voisin
le Bretonneux tout à fait et donc du
coup vous allez proposer ces petites
fiches je ne sais pas si on la voit bien
voilà une petite fiche avec derrière un
Code Bar tout à fait voilà les clients
en fait pourront aller en caisse et
simplement passer cette cette petite
fiche et du coup donner un don de 2 € à
votre association alors non seulement un
don de 2 € mais s veulent ils peuvent
passer plusieurs fois laffiche et donc
faire un don de 4 6 8 voir même 10 €
pourquoi pas hein alors en dessous il y
a je pense 27 association voilà il y a
27 associations qui vont être dans une
trentaine de magasins et donc comment s
fait le choix en fait parce queil y
avait auparavant c'était des
associations plutôt portées sur
l'international cette année ça change un
peu en fait c'est une opération qui est
historiquement organisé par le Conseil
général le Conseil Général connaît bien
ses associations historiquement en effet
on travaillait avec le département de
coopération décentralisé euh du conseil
général donc c'était plutôt des
associations de solidarité
internationale ou euh voilà d'action
d'action Nord-Sud et pour la première
fois cette année euh le le programme
s'est ouvert aux associations locales
euh voilà parce que d'une année à
l'autre on le faisait toujours avec plus
d'association et les résultats étaient
euh étaient plutôt positif et donc voilà
l'action locale on a entendu parler a
voulu se greffer à à l'opération et donc
voilà on est très heureux que le Conseil
général vous avez choisi du coup les
associations c'est le cons génal c'est
le conseil général le Conseil Général
connaît ces associations c'est c'est il
sait il sait il connaît les associations
qui sont efficace sur le territoire
comme baliski et donc nous a proposé ces
associations et sur toutes les petites
cartes vous voyez vous voyez le logo du
conseil général ça rassure aussi les
citoyens de savoir que c'est des
associations il y a le tampon du conseil
général euh voilà
on est sûr on est sûr de leur efficacité
s alors à peu près combien en fait
d'euros pensez-vous récolter pour ces
associations grâce à cette opération
alors en en moyenne sur un magasin de
type supermarché on récolte 1000 € par
association mais bon voilà
historiquement on fait un petit peu plus
donc on espère que baliski entre autres
collectera plus mais surtout c'est pas
qu'une c'est pas qu'une histoire de
collecte il y a vraiment trois impacts
sociaux à ces opérations le premier
évident voilà c'est la collecte le
second c'est aussi de donner de la
visibilité aux associations le
supermarché c'est l'endroit où il y a le
plus de passage sur un territoire et
donc c'est une belle vitrine une belle
opportunité de visibilité qui est donné
aux organisations que de pouvoir
présenter leurs activités et troisième
impact c'est aussi l'opportunité de
créer du lien de recréer du lien en
local pourquoi pas de recruter des
nouveaux bénévoles des nouveaux membres
des nouveaux donateurs de créer du lien
avec le directeur du supermarché qui va
voilà vous inviter pourquoi pas à venir
refaire une collecte alimentaire ce
qu'on a déjà fait voilà avec c'est même
avec ouais tout à fait Carrefour Market
à voisin le Bretonneux on a déjà fait ça
une fois et ainsi qu'à SuperU gui en
cours d'accord pierre manuel grand nous
parlerit de de 1000 € à peu près par
magasin je crois que baliski en a besoin
ces ansci balisk en a bien besoin
effectivement parce que nous vivons à la
fois de subventions des collectivités
locales de dons privés d'entrepris ou de
particulier il se trouve qu'une
subvention importante celle du conseil
général a baissé de façon significative
5000 € de moins et donc nous faisons des
efforts pour compenser en quelque sorte
ce manque à gagner parce que nous avons
besoin de ces recettes ça fait 2 ans
quand même qu'on a des des budgets
déficitaires à hauteur de 2500 3000 €
voilà donc c'est vraiment merci Monsieur
grange de nous avoir retenu avec le
conseil général parce que ce sera
vraiment bienvenu jusqu'à présent on n
pas voulu diminuer le nombre de familles
accueillies parce que la conjoncture
fait que pour nous c'est une priorité
alors un dernier point au-delà de ces
cartes donc de 2 € vous lancez également
d'autres opérations vous avez lancé
l'arrondi dans les magasins franc prix
donc par exemple si on
paye quelques centimes on peut aller à
l'arrondi supérieure et ça devrait
continuer exactement donc en fait on on
est sur on est en train de lancer un
grand programme solidaire qui s'appelle
l'arrondi et c'est l'idée de donner
quelques centimes à quelques euros à
partir des actes de la vie quotidienne
on le fait depuis quel depuis plusieurs
années déjà sur les bulletins de salaire
donc on a des grandes entreprises qui
qui l'ont mis en place chaque mois vous
reversez
quelques euros à partir de votre net à
payer l'employeur à bond des double les
dons et là en effet on est en train de
le lancer sur d'autres supports donc
bientôt sur le relevé bancaire mensuel
et surtout donc dans la distribution
avec cette enseigne en effet franc prix
on est en train de le déployer
progressivement pour l'instant on est
seulement dans une dizaine de magasins
pas encore dans les Evelin mais on va y
venir moi je suis originaire des Evelin
donc j'ai à cœur que ce soit également
dans le département et d'ici 6 mois on
sera dans 300 magasin et surtout on est
en train de discuter avec d'autres
enseignes pour faire de cette mécanique
un réflexe solidaire très bien je vous
remercie tous les deux d'avoir été
présents avec nous sur ce plateau et
puis on rappelle l'opération tout ce
weekend et on pe
mag Magin sur le site du conseén le site
du Conseil Général qui devrait
s'afficher juste sur l'écran voilà pour
ce qui voudrait retrouver du coup les
lieux où aller merci en tout cas à tous
les deux et on passe maintenant au
dossier de la
semaine alors nous allons nous
intéresser secteur du social un secteur
qui ne connaît pas la crise pourquoi et
que se cache-t-il derrière ces métiers
réponse avec ce dossier réalisé avec
Jonathan villman et Patrick Jacques de
dixmud les métiers du social ont plus
que jamais le vent en poupe en
Île-de-France on compte 320000 postes
dans ce secteur dans le top 3 les
assistantes maternelles et auxiliaires
de vie représentent 80000 emplois et les
éducateurs 20000 le travail social
regroupe bien d'autres métiers leur
domaine d'intervention l'aide sociale
l'éducation spécialisée l'animation
socioculturelle et l'aide à domicile
mais malgré des débouchés importants les
structures ont souvent du mal à recruter
c'est le cas de e aprè service une
société qui propose des solutions de
garde et d'accompagnement de jeunes
handicapés romain en est l'un des
fondateurs c'est par le biais de son
engagement associatif qu'il a réalisé
les besoins dans ce secteur on a démarré
en 2008 avec une association qui
s'appelle d'un corps à l'autre qui
propose des activités sportives aux
enfants en situation handicap quel
qu'ils soit on prend et du handicap
moteur et du handicap mental et en fait
à force de côtoyer les familles
puisqu'on en a un peu plus de 300
maintenant qui côtoient nos structures
un peu partout dans l'île-de-fance
beaucoup de familles sont venus nous
poser des des demandes au niveau des
prises en charges éducatives après
l'établissement ou pour certains même en
journée quand ils étaient pas scolarisé
à temps plein ou voir déscolarisé
totalement pour par manque de structure
avec deux collègues il lance il y a un
an et après service et les demandes AFF
flu 70 familles font aujourd'hui appel à
eux ils emploient 37 personnes dont 8 en
plein éducateur spécialisé moniteur
assistant de vie sociale et a
médico-psychologique un nombre encore
insuffisant on a en poste des offres à
peu près tous les jours parce qu'on a
des nouvelles demandes tous les toutes
les semaines entre 3 à 5 qui aboutissent
pas forcément mais on a régulièrement
des nouvelles demandes et par exemple
juste par pour des chiffres à l'heure
actuelle il nous manque encore 11
salariés alors que la rentrée était déjà
il y a un
mois il nous manque 11 personnes pour
s'occuper d'enfants qui sont pour
l'instant sans solution parce que les
parents n n'ont pas d'autres person
person ver qui se tourn Céline a intégré
la société cet été elle s'occupe depuis
2 mois de Léa une jeune autiste sourde
qui participe aux activités de
l'association d'un corps à l'autre elle
l'accompagne lors de son activité avant
de la ramener à la maison j'ai des
objectifs qui ont été élaboré avec la
famille donc notamment c'est travailler
sur l'autonomie et sur la communication
donc à travers tous les actes de la vie
quotidienne ça va être bah l'habillage
le
déshabillage le bain pas encore mais ça
vient pouvoir aller aux toilettes savoir
manger toute seule travailler sur ces
axes là pour qu'elle soit de plus en
plus autonome et qu'elle évolue dans le
bon sens c'est aussi l'emmener sur des
activités à l'extérieur donc le sport ou
alors la piscine l'emmener au parc pour
qu'elle aussi des activités de loisir et
de détente céline est passionnée de son
travail des remises en question
quotidiennes mais la valorisation de
faire avancer petit à petit Léa diplômée
depuis début juillet elle n'a eu aucun
mal à décrocher ce premier emploi pour
elle le secteur n'est pas valorisé
peut-être c'est de la la mes
connaissances je pense que les gens ils
savent peut-être pas que dans ce
milieu-là ben déjà dans le milieu social
on fait rarement référence au handicap
je pense que dans le milieu social on
voit plus la protection de l'enfance et
l'exclusion mais voilà pour les
éducateurs spécialisés et dans les
autres professions du du champ social il
y a plein de domaines il y a plein de
métiers et il y a de la place et je
pense que les gens ne savent pas ce qui
se cache derrière le le champ social et
toutes les opportunités qu'on peut qu'on
peut avoir c'est pas forcément très bien
reconnu c'est pas forcément très bien
payer mais il y a quand même des gens
qui sont passionnés par le métier qui
passionnés par ce qu'ils font par les
enfants et ces personnesl que nous on
recherche donc on arrive quand même à en
trouver beaucoup une vocation plus qu'un
métier au niveau salarial les
travailleurs sociaux débutent
généralement à 1300 € hors prime pour
arriver à 2500 en fin de carrière pour
faire connaître ce secteur professionnel
et centres de formation vont à la
rencontre des adolescents qui se
questionnent sur leur orientation
c'était le cas ce mardi à la Cité des
Métiers à trappe face à eux beaucoup de
jeunes femmes certaines déjà bien décidé
à faire carrière dans le social j'ai une
idée je voudrais être éducatrice
spécialisée donc avec quel public je ne
sais pas encore je pense les handicapés
d'autres venus plutôt pour découvrir le
secteur je m'attendais pas à ce qu'il y
ait autant de choses que ce soit autant
dans différents domaines en fait avec
les enfants les personnes âgées et
cetera même enfin je viens d'apprendre
queon pouvait même avoir des assistantes
sociales ou des eduxp dans dans l'armée
enfin je je m' attendais vraiment pas
quoi l'occasion pour ces jeunes
bachelières de penser à leur avenir et à
leur carrière professionnelle Guilan
Peltier bonjour vous êtes attaché de
direction à Buc ressources oui c'est un
domaine finalement qui ne connaît pas la
crise comment ça s'explique
malheureusement ben d'abord le
vieillissement de la population dont on
a beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps avec
les les les adaptations les besoins en
accueil les besoins essentiellement de
personnel à domicile la petite enfance
énormément puisquon est quand même je
crois le premier pays européen à
continuer à faire des des enfants et
puis sur l'Île-de-France un besoin
décuplé puisque la condensation des
travailleurs se trouve ici avec des
familles des enfants et des besoins de
prise en charge de ces jeunes enfants et
puis malheureusement avec la crise et
puis les problèmes sociaux que ça peut
représenter des besoins qui vont aussi
émerger l'accompagnement de de ces
familles en difficulté de la jeunesse en
difficulté donc l'éducation spécialisée
restera aussi euh euh au cœur de le
Centre d'analyse stratégique parle de
300 à 350000 emplois créés d'ici 2030
chaque année bu ressource forme 1000
étudiants de l'assistante sociale au
directeur d'établissement et 185
éducateurs spécialisés et moniteurs
éducateurs sur concours ce ne sont que
des formations par alternance hein avec
la théorie et la pratique avec des
statuts différents soit des voies
directes de l'apprentissage ou des
situations d'emploi mais c'est de toute
façon de la formation professionnelle
et donc de l'alternance systématique
c'est quelque chose qui est finalement
essentiel c'est important d'aller se
confronter très rapidement à la réalité
à l'expérience et puis c'est une
formation qui se fait essentiellement
par la transmission des savoirs par les
professionnels la formation des
travailleurs sociaux est en pleine
mutation les formations de niveau 5
devraient être regroupées en 2015 comme
les assistants de vie sociale vie
scolaire et haine médico-psychologique
les diplômés d'état éducateurs
spécialisés assistant de servicees
social conseiller en économie sociale et
familiale et éducateur de jeunes enfants
exerce 3 ans d'études mais non encore
pour le moment qu'une reconnaissance à
bac+ 2 les choses pourraient là aussi
changer nous retrouvons à Manil et amo
le directeur de l'association Passerelle
Paul emploie cinq éducateurs spécialisés
et pour eux non plus ce n'est pas le
boulot qui manque il est même difficile
de recruter des hommes diplômés il y a
beaucoup de femmes qui cherch du travail
qui sont éducat spécialisés mais des
hommes il un peu moins et c'est bien
dans des équipes en tout cas de
prévention spécialisé qu' a un équilibre
entre voilà entre homme et femme voilà
dans la relation avec les jeunes aussi
c'est important voilà donc oui on a un
peu difficulté à recruter des hommes
diplômés en PR spécialisé présente
depuis 2005 à gui en cour et depuis 2011
à manilamo passerel a réussi à tisser
des liens avec les jeunes des environs
l'objectif gagner leur confiance et
renouer les liens avec les institutions
ça une demande en terme d'emploi de
formation des problèmes de justice des
problèmes familiaux toutes sortes de
problèmes des problèmes financiers des
problèmes d'hébergement enfin toutes
sortes de problèmes donc c'est un
accompagnement global du jeune et de sa
famille l'association vient ainsi en
aide à 400 jeunes petit à petit les
éducateurs les poussent à se prendre en
main et les incite à réaliser de vraies
actions citoyennes chaque année un
voyage humanitaire est organisé à
Madagascar ou à Haïti bien souvent un
premier pas pour ces jeunes vers des
actions de solidarité tous ici sont
aujourd'hui investis dans des
associations locales mir et wid font
partie de humanitaire partenaire de
passerelle il mènne des actions dans des
pays en développement Paul et son équipe
les ont aidé dans leur démarche
administrative depuis l'association est
lancée mais passerel c'est reste il
reste à l'écart mais en moindre si on
moindre problème ou question ils sont là
pour nous éer quo actuellement Walid
cherche du matériel de football pour
équiper un club malgache ces jeunes sont
à l'origine d'action plus local Karim
s'occupe de l'association promouvoir qui
a mise en place un réseau d'échange de
savoir S a un jeune qui a besoin de
cours d'informatique on peut il y aura
un bénévole qui lui donnera des cours et
ce jeunel rendra ce un service à une
autre personne ça peut être dans la
mécanique dans la menuiserie c'est
chacun rend service à l'autre sans que
ce soit la même personne Karim soutient
également des projets d'art urbain le
but faire bouger les jeunes du quartier
du Pont du routtoir à Guy encour Anthony
souhaiterait faire de même sur Manille
et il y a pas de vrais échange avec les
élus locaux et les jeunes vraiment du
Buisson
donc qu'on essaie de leur montrer qu'au
final on n'est pas
juste des gens qui sont là à traîner ou
non on est sur le buisson justement il y
a beaucoup de personnes investies et
c'est ce qu'on essaie de de prouver pour
l'association Passerelle cette forte
mobilisation des jeunes est le signe
d'un défi réussi là on a un bon nombre
de jeunes qui s'en sort donc ça c'est
vrai que c'est ça fait vraiment plaisir
et en effet quand on va des jeunes
rentrer dans C dans ces dynamique
citoyenne où ils vont passer aussi le
rela à d'autres jeunes des quartiers là
ça c'est vraiment intéressant voilà
qu'ils accompagnent des jeunes des
handicapés ou encore des personnes âgées
les travailleurs sociaux ne connaissent
pas la crise et si leur salaire
n'aténueent pas des sommets ils peuvent
se targuer de vivre de leur
passion et deux dates à retenir dans
l'agenda samedi 5 octobre le centre
commercial des se marares à hencour
lance commerce en fait avec des
animations à partir de 10h suivie d'une
nuit blanche animation artistique
cinématographique de 17h à l'aube vous
retrouverez la programmation sur le site
de la ville et lundi Créactive
l'association des entrepreneurs au
féminin organise une soirée
d'information pour avoir les clés du
pilotage d'entreprise c'est à 19h30
Promopole de Montini le Bretonneux c'est
la fin de ce filcho merci d'avoir été
avec nous je vous donne rendez-vous
jeudi pour prochain pardon pour un
prochain numéro à bientôt bonne
soirée